kukin was one of the fiercest Warriors
Ireland had ever seen in the heat of
battle he would use his special ability
called the riastrad and transform into a
9-ft tall giant killing anything in his
path Friend or Foe one day he came home
from a battle and threatened to kill
everyone in the homestead unless he was
given an opponent to fight his uncle the
king of olster sent out a group of naked
women instead even though he was a
renowned fighter kollin was also still
just a young boy so he turned away from
the site in embarrassment with kullin
distracted the men of the Fortress were
able to restrain him and dunk him into a
tub of water but kolan was so fired up
with rage that the water turned to steam
immediately the water in the next tub
came to a roiling boil and the water in
the third tub merely turned warm and
that's how you calm down a raving
murderous Giant